hey guys Google had an event today where
they completely surprised Us by
announcing the totally out of the blue
pixel 8 and pixel 8 Pro and the pixel
Watch 2 that somehow never leaked it
just completely caught us off guard I
hope you can detect my sarcasm through
the internet but hey we did get an event
and it has some stuff that I was really
looking forward to pixel 8 and 8 Pro
mostly because I've been a pixel fan
even though I know it has these big
flaws like the tensor G2 had subpar
performance and the somewhat average
battery life but like I I still like the
pixel and there's a lot that I was
looking forward to for the next stuff so
they delivered on a lot of that stuff
but it also comes with a new price so
okay on the outside pixel 8 and 8 Pro do
still look like pixels right I told you
they were sticking with this design
language with the visor because it's
very recognizable and they finally have
that going for them but this year it
just feels like they rounded everything
off like that's the big visible design
update this year everything's a bit more
rounded and then there's the new colors
now honestly I'm just going to say it I
think it's been a pretty boring year for
phone colors across the board just
putting it out there but with this one
it's Hazel Rose and obsidian for the
pixel 8 and then obsidian porcelain and
this new blue color called baay I think
the blue is probably the most
interesting of the whole lineup combined
with the new matte finish that's on the
back of all the pros I love that I think
it might be my favorite alongside matte
black maybe it's a tossup between the
two but then around the front both
displays have actually gotten better so
the bezels are a bit thinner and they
look pretty uniform all the way around
to me and then they're both dramatically
brighter up to 2,000 nits Peak
brightness on the pixel 8 and 2400 nits
on the 8 Pro I think that's the highest
I've ever seen in a phone so I think it
should look really good both indoors and
Outdoors and then also the smaller pixel
8 is now 120 HZ as well love that I know
people love just dismissing 120 HZ on
cheaper phones but we there now it's not
ltpo yet that's still just the pro but
yeah just looking at these screens for
the limited time that I spent with them
I am very excited to get them out in the
real world they're calling it an actua
display and a super actua display not
sure why but I guess you got to name
everything but anyway this year the
really big physical change we're getting
with these phones I'm going to say is
the new tensor G3 chip so it's a new
third generation of Google silicon
paired with 8 gigs of RAM on the pixel 8
and 12 gigs of RAM on the pixel 8 Pro
and to be honest Google didn't really
talk that much about or at least Flex
very much of like just raw performance
improvements like it's not really about
that I'm going to have to test these
phones to see if they actually improved
a lot as far as CPU and GPU and just
overall power so definitely get
subscribed to be first to see those
reviews when they come out also here are
the battery sizes the new batteries of
these new phones they're both a tiny bit
bigger than last year but really the
story with the tensor G3 is there's way
more TPU and way more processing power
for AI related tasks and that checks out
because the pixel story has always been
all about the software and that's still
super true with these there is so much
software like the pixel is basically the
smartest smartphone in the room it's not
going to wow you with amazing numbers or
incredible build quality or huge
Hardware features or anything like that
it's going to wow you with very clever
software at every corner so here we're
talking there's a new Google Assistant
feature where if you're on a web page in
Chrome you can ask the assistant to
summarize the web page for you and then
using the same Tech I imagine that's in
Google bard it'll quickly give you a
three or four bullet point summary
that's hopefully accurate speech to text
is also now even faster and more
accurate it's completely on device and
does a much better job also at knowing
that ums and O are not part of your
actual sentence so it doesn't write them
down that's smart they're doing more
stuff with the front faceing camera to
make stuff like Face Unlock and
unlocking stuff in apps more secure
there there's also a new fix it feature
which will proofread your messages built
into the keyboard before you send them
with things like grammar and all that
one of The Crazy Ones is the new call
screen voice so if you've used a pixel
you know about call screen before which
is you're getting a call it's an unknown
number you just let the Google Assistant
screen the call the new one has a much
more human voice that I honestly don't
really know if it's a robot voice or
just a recording of a human but it's
much more human sounding and then also
it has uh the chips that pop up that you
can hit to respond to people that are
now context aware so if it listens to
somebody say hey I'm a UPS driver you
can now hit a button that immediately
says oh you can leave the package at the
doorstep I got to record this I'll just
let you listen to it hi I'm a Google
Virtual calling assistant recording this
call on behalf of the person you're
trying to reach can you say what you're
calling
about I'm trying to pack drop off a
package for
Kenny they said you can go ahead and
leave the package by the front door
okay thanks that's
great great I'll see you soon so yeah
that that's pretty good to me it sounds
very human but again I don't know it's I
could I just literally be a human
recording either way it says it's a
virtual assistant but what would a pixel
be without some camera magic so let's
just jump into the new camera stuff with
the pixel cuz there's a lot of software
magic here lot of software magic so the
pixel 8 and 8 Pro now share the same
upgraded 50 megap main camera system
then the 8 also has a 12 megap Ultra
wide but the 8 Pro just sends it all the
way with a 48 megapixel Ultra wide and a
48 megap 5x telephoto and I also really
like the new camera app layout which is
now separated basically into photo and
video mode and then all the various
settings and modes are inside of each so
I think it makes a lot of intuitive
sense you can just switch to photo and
then go to a specific photo mode there's
manual controls it's not the first time
I've seen it laid out this way but when
you get so much stuff happening in the
camera you don't want to move it out or
hide it you just need to sort of
organize it in a capable way I think
this does a good job so I'll have to
save my photo and video quality analysis
for the full review but like I said
there's a lot of software features that
they've added that just seem they just
get more and more wild as you go on so
the really insane one is the magic
editor so you've probably already seen
you can erase people from the background
of photos with magic eraser but now this
magic editor will let you straight up
select subjects and just move them
around and completely alter the entire
photo with just a few Taps so they
showed me this example of like moving a
subject to a different spot in a photo
on the beach but there's also all kinds
of other demos of like changing the sky
or changing Shadows or you know all
kinds of other stuff honestly it seems
like nothing is off limits and then
there's also a feature I didn't get
footage of but it's called best take
which is like you know when you're
taking a photo of like a group of a
bunch of people and you're like all
right everybody try to smile at the same
time and you you take a bunch of photos
but there's always somebody blinking in
one of them it's never perfect with
everyone's faces you probably see where
this is going so Google detects that
you're taking a burst photo of a bunch
of people and it will take all of those
together and give you the ability to tap
on people's faces and change them to a
different instance of a different face
that they were making at a different
time just to stitch together this
Frankenstein photo with everyone having
perfect faces even though it's moment
that never happened what is a photo but
then there's another one called audio
eraser uh it's a video editing feature
it's just on the pixel 8 and 8 Pro but
you can actually use it on any video
you've ever taken in your library but
that literally just erases background
sounds from like a video of a subject it
supposedly works really well I got to
test this on more stuff but the one they
showed me worked amazingly well and all
of this is basically along the theme of
awesome software magic enabled by tensor
G3 like all of the neural cores and all
the things that it's doing with AI
processing is what's enabling all of
this awesome weird fancy software magic
stuff and then there's two other little
things that didn't really fit into the
rest of this video but one is there's a
new hole on the back of the pro phone as
you could probably see and that is a
temperature sensor yeah actually so
there's a new thermometer app on the
phone and when you open it it asks you
to select a material to measure the
surface temperature of I guess to be the
most accurate so you pick your material
and then you just get up close to your
subject like within 2 in of it and tap
to measure and you get your temperature
which is it it works it's pretty neat I
guess I don't know that I would use this
very much you may also notice that
humans are missing from the object
selection menu because measuring human
temperature is still awaiting FDA
approval maybe that'll get added to the
menu when it gets approved later this
year although I guess technically you
could just tell it you're a ceramic or
like a hot liquid or something and
measure yourself self anyway I don't
know whatever it there's a temperature
sensor now on the 8 Pro and but the
other thing is number two the haptics oh
my God I was typing on these phones and
this this is like the number one thing I
noticed on the 8 Pro is the haptics are
so much stronger I mean I was just
poking around the UI and scrolling a
bunch but especially when I was typing
the haptics are super strong and really
refined so there's a difference between
strong haptics and like clean refined
haptics this was both and I think that's
super underrated I don't know if they're
going to mention this or put it in the
marketing materials at all but but I
just loveed the haptics from the hour or
two that I spent with this phone all
right quick injection there's actually
one more thing I wanted to mention with
these that's called video boost and it's
one of the weirdest I don't even know if
I can call it a software feature
actually but it's one of the weirdest
things yet so first of all it's only
available on the pro pixel second of all
it doesn't actually launch with the
phone it's coming soon or later but
basically what it is is you take some
video video on your pixel and it looks
okay at first but then you have it
uploaded to the cloud where it then
processes overnight or for a few hours
and then comes back to you with a result
that looks dramatically better better
HDR plus better color grading and looks
much better than the video you
originally took I don't know why it's
only on the pro phone I don't know why
it has to upload to other servers I
don't even know what's happening it's
just this weird video magic feature it's
called video boost we'll see what
happens if it actually comes out by
review time but just wanted to throw
that in there another weird feature so
then the new prices so pixel 8 is going
to start at $6.99 which is 100 bucks
more than last year and then the pixel 8
Pro is going to start at $9.99 I think
you can justify it though I mean the Bas
pixel just got upgraded to 120 HZ
display to a much brighter display with
thinner bezels to the tensor G3 it's got
a new primary camera that's the same as
a more expensive phone so I still feel
like that's a fair price for it even
though it's not the bargain of the year
like it was before and then the other
massive update that's for both of these
phones this is awesome is 7 years of os
security and feature drop updates for
the 8 and 8 Pro 7even years which seems
like something they probably should have
already been doing with Google's own
phone running Google's own chips and
Google's own software but yeah that's
think about that that's pretty sick
they're leading the way this is a phone
that's going to get its last software up
date in
2030 good looks Google but also yeah
they announced an update to the pixel
Watch 2 it is in the same super Sleek
Pebble design so it's going to look the
same from the outside but now inside
there's a new quad core processor that
should speed things up significantly and
also potentially extend the battery life
by a little bit cuz they're promising 24
hours but with always on display on now
instead of off and there's a bunch of
newly redesigned apps like Gmail and
calendar and then it just felt like they
added a bunch of stuff that we we also
recently saw added to the Apple watch so
there's a new safety check feature that
works almost exactly like the one apple
just announced they also added a skin
temperature sensor that can be helpful
for monitoring patterns they also now
have Auto workout start and stop
detection and they also added backup and
restore which actually other watches
have had for a while and they should
have had this ages ago but they also now
have that if you look at the back of the
watch there's a bunch of improved
sensors that should better monitor heart
rate and Health Data while you're moving
around a lot more vigorously and this
watch will launch at the same price that
last year's did so$ 3.49 for the Wi-Fi
only and 3.99 starting for the LTE watch
and that's a pretty good spot for our
segue to the sponsor of this video which
is the dbrand ghost case they're going
to make one for these new pixels pixel 8
and 8 Pro so you can see that matte
finish or that new color through the
case while keeping it protected and then
even though it doesn't have G2 wireless
charging like it was rumored that they
might that didn't stop dbrand from just
putting a MAG safe compatible ring on
the back anyway and I also kind of like
what they did with with the question
mark design compared to the classic
apple mag safe layout but also I like
the fact that dbr says the ghost case
will never turn yellow unlike every
other clear case so if you want to pick
up a ghost which will never turn yellow
I'll leave the link below and so that's
it let me know what you guys want to see
in the reviews of each of these devices
the phones the watches because my name
is Marquez brownley and it is TE toober
officially and there's going to be a
bunch of videos in the next couple weeks
so stay tuned for that stuff get
subscribed all right catch you in the
next one
[Music]
peace